what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down episode 20 of
Attack on Titan season 4 in which Aaron
used the true power of His attack Titan
to directly influence the past this was
by far the most complex use of Titan
abilities that we've ever seen and today
I'll be explaining exactly how it
happened and also how Aaron knew this
moment was coming for over four years
before we get into it though I do these
breakdowns every week so I'd really
appreciate if you hit that sub button if
you haven't already and as usual drop a
like if you like the video
okay so in the last episode Zeke gained
control of the founding Titan which
gives him power over every single Elden
on the planet with this potential he
could finally complete his euthanization
plan and sterilize all subjects of Emir
however being the amazing brother that
he is he only wants to do this with
Aaron by his side in Zeke's mind he
assumes the reason Aaron betrayed him is
because he was brainwashed by Grisha to
become an Aldine restorationist which is
of course what happened to Zeke himself
when he was growing up for that reason
he uses the power of the founder to take
them into grish's memories so he can
make Aaron realize that he's been
manipulated by their father the first
flashback they visit is one of Aaron
crawling and being held as a baby and I
don't know about you guys but if I
didn't know for a fact this was him then
I would have just assumed this was a
girl regardless of that now is probably
the best time to establish the rules of
traveling through memories and rule
number one is that the Jaeger Bros are
not actually traveling into the past but
rather this is more like a simulation
created by the founding Titan in this
simulation they can witness key moments
from grisha's life but no one can see
them back since everyone is basically an
NPC this brings us to rule number two
which is that because all of these
memories are just visual representations
of things that took place it means that
Zeke and Aaron should not be able to
change how anything plays out we'll get
back to this topic later on to explain
how Aaron did what he did but for the
time being let's focus on Grisha himself
in this memory we can see that he used
his position as a doctor to get close to
Nobles inside the walls and this is one
of the reasons why Kruger thought he'd
make a good spy as a doctor with
knowledge from the outside world Grisha
was one of the best if not the best on
the island and he'd already saved the
people of sugar from a plague a few
years earlier this accomplishment is
most likely how important people inside
the wars heard of him and by getting
close to them Grisha could eventually
find out who has the founding Titan
while observing this memory Zeke thought
that this was just another example of
how his dad was a terrible person since
if his plan had been discovered then it
would have obviously put his new family
at risk despite that Aaron wasn't so
convinced and as they continued to move
through these memories it became clear
that Grisha did learn from the mistakes
he made when raising Zeke that was
proven in this particular flashback when
after only a few years on parodies he
managed to discover the identity of the
true royal family in this scene he
approaches the rice chapel and prepares
to confront the Royals and steal the
fighting Titan but in the end he
couldn't go through with it and returns
to his family back home what this showed
is that he loved his new son too much to
risk losing everything which is in
direct contrast to how he treated Zeke
and was prepared to make his first son a
soldier for an enemy state in that way
Grisha had clearly grown as a person and
it would be a long time until he decided
to visit the rice Chapel again
before we continue there were a few bits
of trivia I wanted to mention the first
being that at this point in the timeline
the king of the walls was URI rice this
means that had Grisha gone down into the
basement that day he would have ended up
fighting him instead of Frida and it's
feasible the fight might have ended
differently after all URI was shown to
have lightning fast reflexes during his
encounter with Kenny Ackerman and at
this time he would have had a shifter
for around six or seven years making him
far more experienced than Freda was when
she was defeated
another piece of trivia was that in this
memory when Grisha discovered the map to
the rice Chapel he then crossed Paws
with Kenny who was now being employed by
the royal family had Kenny found out
what he was hiding in his pocket then
there's a sort of chance he might have
tried to slice his neck which may or may
not have led to Grisha turning into a
Titan so it's just a good thing for
everyone that he was able to leave
without being questioned
now moving on to one of the best scenes
in the episode we see that Grisha fell
asleep in his basement while writing one
of his famous books in his sleep he
starts to receive memories from the
future that belong to present-day Aaron
and we're gonna pause for a second to
explain what exactly is going on
to start things off it's fairly normal
for a Time shift to see memories that
belong to a previous user but when it
comes to Holders of the attack Titan
these guys are sometimes able to see
memories from their future inheritors as
well one example is how back in season 3
Kruger told his successor to save Mikasa
and Armin despite neither of them being
born yet and now in this new episode a
similar thing happens again because
Aaron and his dad are both holders of
the attack Titan Grisha from the pass is
therefore able to see memories that
belong to Aaron in the future in this
specific scene notice how when Aaron
looks down at this picture of Zeke his
dad then immediately reacts and
apologizes to his first son then when
present-day Aaron looks directly at his
raggedy bearded brother Grisha from the
past reacts again as he sees a vision of
a bearded man who he recognizes as Zeke
what this shows is that thanks to his
attack Titan Grisha can occasionally see
the future through Aaron's point of view
and as the video continues we'll break
down how this ability enables them to
communicate through time
anyway after seeing everything so far
Zeke finally realizes that his
assumptions were wrong and their father
didn't bring much Aaron to become an
alien restorationist because of this
Zeke begins to wonder why Aaron then
betrayed him and acts the way he does
since he's doing all the things his
father would have wanted only without
ever being told to do so Aaron goes on
to explain that no one had to make him
this way and that since birth he's just
always had this drive to protect his own
Freedom no matter what the cost in this
memory here we get a look at the crime
scene after Aaron and Mikasa killed
those kidnappers and it was kind of
funny seeing Zeke and his dad react in
the same way this moment here emphasized
just how different the two Jaeger Bros
are since Zeke's backstory made it clear
that he was content to live a life
inside the internment Zone whereas by
contrast Aaron is someone who felt
confined by the walls and was quite
literally willing to kill people who
threatened his freedom
with this difference in character now
being established you might then be
wondering why is he continued to take
them through their dad's memories and
the answer is that he still believed he
could change Aaron's mind in the same
way that Sava once saved him he is now
desperate to save Aaron and so he's not
going to carry out the euthanization
plan until he finds at least one memory
that might change his brother's
perspective
as they walk through flashback off the
flashback we get moments that are subtly
relevant to things that Grisha says
later in the episode for example in this
memory he's taking care of children in
his office and then later when he
confronts the Rye's family he collapses
to his knees saying that he could never
kill kids another instance is how he
casually walks past his father and son
playing with a ball which is something
Zeke always wanted to do and later
Grisha basically apologizes for never
doing this
eventually they get to this memory of
their dad putting the finishing touches
on his notebooks and as he looks at the
key he sends his a presence in the room
this is another example of him receiving
a memory from the future because with
Aaron staring directly at him past
Grisha would have briefly seen a vision
of himself from his son's point of view
to reinforce this point it's worth
remembering that although he previously
commented on Zeke's appearance he never
once mentions what future Aaron looks
like and that's because he doesn't
actually see his younger son given that
the Visions he's receiving are coming
directly from Aaron's own eyes then it
makes perfect sense why he can strongly
feel a presence but can't physically see
him back
anyhow the next flashback is won from
the very first episode of the series and
thanks to everything we know this scene
now has a completely different meaning
in this moment Grisha asks his son why
he wants to join the survey Court to
which Aaron replies that he wants to
know what it's like on the outside and
that if there's no one to carry on all
the deaths up until now will be in vain
that second line is super important
because although Aaron was talking about
the previous Scouts who died in grisha's
mind he was thinking about something
else in this moment he realized that if
he died without competing his mission or
passing on his shifter then the deaths
of Kruger Diner and all the other
restorationists would be in vain it was
these words from his son that convinced
Grisha to go and finally confront the
royal family that day and coincidentally
it also happened to be the same day the
Warriors attacked this coincidence was
confirmed later in the episode when he
spells out that he didn't know which day
the wars were going to be destroyed
switching back to the memory in question
we then get a replay of the scene where
he promises to show Aaron what's in the
basement this time around the camera
pans out to reveal Aaron's standing
there watching the moment Play Out and
because of grisha's future memory
inheritance he feels the presence in
front of him again just like he did in
the basement he then makes his final
Journey to the rice Chapel almost a
decade after he first attempted to
confront them and this sequence was
undeniably the best part of the episode
as he begs Frida to save the people of
the Island from the Titans outside the
walls you can see that she does
genuinely have some concern for what
he's saying since the real Frida rice
wanted to save Humanity on parodies
however it wasn't long until she was
overtaken by the will of Carl Fritz who
began ranting about how eldian should
accept their fate because if they die it
means that fewer people outside the
walls have to suffer
this way of thinking is very similar to
Zeke which is why he had no complaints
about what she said but on the other
hand Aaron was getting angrier and
angrier as she kept talking remember
this memory is taking place on the same
day his mother was eaten by a Titan and
here you have someone trying to justify
her death and the death of everyone else
who was killed by The Warriors his
intense feelings of Rage could be felt
by his dad in the past hence why he
reacts in this moment and it's about
time we break this moment down step by
step Point number one is that when this
really happened all those years ago
Chris's attack Titan enabled him to
receive memories from this version of
Aaron the memories he received in this
scene were essentially a live stream
from Aaron's perspective meaning that
Grisha was experiencing this one moment
from both his own point of view and from
Aaron's point of view as well he could
feel the same emotions his son was
feeling and see the same things his son
was seeing a connection made possible by
the attack Titan
Point number two is that Zeke took his
brother into this memory without knowing
this ability was a thing so while Zeke
could only watch on it was Aaron
specifically who had the power to
communicate with their dad that's why
when Grisha drops to his knees and
hesitates to kill the royal family his
son tells him to stand and then that
memory of him saying that is sent into
the pause where his dad receives the
message
using this method era motivates his
father by giving him a speech that is
heavily inspired by the one Kruger game
13 years ago and as it turns out this is
exactly what Grisha needed to hear to go
ballistic and Massacre the rise family
an interesting thing to know is that we
got this shot of Aaron kissing Historia
which is a reference to the medal
ceremony four years ago during that
ceremony Aaron experienced all of his
father's memories from the rice Chapel
including the memories that Grisha
received from the future what this means
in reality is that four years ago Aaron
didn't just see his dad's memories but
he also saw memories that were sent to
his dad by Future versions of himself
ever since he kissed the hand he knew it
was him that motivated his father to
kill the Rices and on top of that he saw
a different memory that made him make
this face if you're wondering what that
other memory could be then we need to
flash forward to after Grisha emerges
from his Titan body and a nice detail
was that he took this syringe from the
rice Chapel which he would later use on
Aaron regardless of that the main point
here is that in this scene Grisha
confirms that he's seen memories from a
future version of Aaron that's even
further in the future than the Aaron
we've seen based on the context of what
he's saying it shouldn't be hard to
guess what he's talking about here and
because Aaron from the medal ceremony
saw everything Grisha saw it means this
same vision was shown to him as well
as a quick side note before we continue
I just thought it would be funny to
highlight how much of a coward Rod rice
was during this whole interaction since
with his wife and children being in
potential danger he was somehow the
first one to try and make an escape this
cowardice was displayed again many years
later when he wanted Historia to shorten
her lifespan by inheriting the founder
instead of Simply doing it himself
now moving on we've established that in
the rice Chapel Grisha saw two sets of
future Memories the first set of future
memories belonged to this errand and
they gave Grisha the resolve he needed
to kill the royal family while the
second set of future memories belonged
to an errand that we haven't even seen
yet and those memories showed him
something terrible another thing we've
established is that four years ago when
Aaron kiss historius hand he saw all of
grisha's memories from the chapel which
included those two sets of memories from
the future as a result he's known for a
long time about this terrible future
that's meant to happen and it's heavily
implied that Aaron himself is the cause
with that said the last two questions
from this episode that I thought might
need explaining were how was Grisha able
to hug Zeke and why would he still give
Aaron the founding Titan despite not
wanting the future he saw to happen
to answer that first question because
Aaron is staring directly at his brother
it means that his dad is able to see
where Zeke is just like when they were
in the basement he then goes to hug his
son since he knows where Zeke is
standing in relation to himself and in
the past Dimension this seems to result
in contact I'm sure if someone in the
past was to walk by they wouldn't
actually see Zeke in fact all they see
is Grisha hugging thin air but because
we're seeing this in the past Dimension
it gives off a powerful illusion that
this is really happening of course it
needs to be said that this is only
possible because of the attack Titan's
power since if their dad had any other
shifter then he wouldn't be able to see
the future through Aaron's eyes this
emotional moment was enough physique to
acknowledge Grisha as his dad because
we've known all along that he wanted his
fatherly love and the reason he had all
this hatred inside him is since he never
truly received it until now
finally the biggest remaining question
coming out of this episode is why would
Grisha still give Aaron the attack Titan
if he didn't want the terrible future he
saw to happen this is a mystery that has
at least three separate valid reasons
and yeah I'm gonna start with the one
that's the most obvious during this
scene when he asked Zeke to stop Aaron
Grisha had no idea that earlier that day
his wife had been eaten by a Titan if we
flash forward to the moment he finds out
his expression completely changes and
the first words he says are that Aaron
needs to avenge his mother Grisha knows
more than anyone on the island that
Malia the ones responsible for
destroying the walls but with his time
as the attack Titan running out the only
person who can avenge Carla is Aaron
this brings us to reason number two
which is that due to the curse of Emir
Grisha had to pass his shifter to
someone and he already established that
his son might be a good choice earlier
he realized that Aaron had a strong
desire to be free which is an integral
part of being the attack Titan and it's
why he was prepared to tell his son the
truth about the world
to put it simply if he didn't pass it to
Aaron then there was no one worthy that
he could pass it to and if he didn't
give it to anyone then there's a chance
to shifter would have fallen into
Molly's hands after his death since the
power would be inherited by a newborn
aldian anywhere in the world he must
have figured it was a safer option to
give it to his son and hopefully in the
future things can work themselves out
finally the third reason he chose to
make this decision is that not doing so
would have created a paradox since
Grisha already knows that future Aaron
possesses the attack Titan if he
willingly chose to avoid his future then
he had no idea what would have happened
I mean for all he knows he might have
started fading away because if Aaron
never gets the attack Titan then future
Aaron wouldn't have been there to
motivate Grisha in the chapel either way
Grisha had no way of knowing what would
happen if he didn't follow the
predetermined path so this is likely a
factor in why he did what he did
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 20 of Attack on Titan season 4
and I hope you clear some things up as
the shifter abilities can get super
confusing if you enjoyed the video then
I'd appreciate if you hit that sub
button and let me know in the comments
what you thought of the episode until
the next one peace out